we turned the phone line and find
another champion Philadelphia Eagle Tyra
and Zach Ertz here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you Zach
how you doing I'm doing fine how was
fouling last night how was that for you
it was definitely a cool experience you
know watching those shows growing up you
see all the past champions go on there
and for us to go out there not only by
myself but to have all my friends up
there with me was a ton of fun
definitely an experience I won't forget
so and yesterday we as sports fans
thanks to the brilliance of NFL Films
were taken inside that trick play the
fourth down play at the end of the first
half the Philly special as it is known
and I could see you you were you were in
the periphery of the conversation of
what Foles had with Doug Peterson and
obviously in that huddle walk me through
that fourth down a moment Zach when you
were going through it yourself yeah you
know I think we had a play call up
before that and then I think they called
a timeout correct correct sir that's
when I thought you were in a settle for
a field goal at that point to be honest
with you ok we'll probably kick a field
at this point and then I'm walking over
there and I'm hearing them talk about
really stressful as everyone knows what
it's called now I'm like waiting for the
one from the one-yard line and we're
gonna call Philly special with troy
burton throw on the ball myself al Shawn
Nelson aren't even in the progression
we're gonna throw the ball to Nick for a
touchdown on fourth and 1 from the one I
honestly can't really believe it at the
time but obviously it worked out for a
former quarterback made great throw Nick
is a very underrated athlete
so I mean obviously he was able to catch
the ball but call that play on fourth
and one right before half when probably
99% of coaches would would have just
taken the point so this you just playing
the game and I think it speaks volumes
about our head coach so you you have no
quarterbacking history and all Zach for
you to make that throw potentially in
Philly special I played it one year of
high school
and then I moved wide receiver from
there so my so so my history of position
was a lot further back though and Trey
Trey obviously played it in Kyle
so I never even got to look
unfortunately well you know what I'm
trying to do because I like going next
level as a broadcaster everybody's
trying to make a quarterback controversy
out of foals and when so I want to make
one out of you and Trey Burton right now
what do you think I think I saw a better
ball today I'm not gonna back down from
that there we go
your competitor that's that better of
you coming out Chris Brockman tweet that
out quarterback controversy nobody ever
saw coming from at rich jaws and show
and let's let's stir it up right here
fire mojo so what was it like cuz I know
you're really tight obviously with Wentz
when he went down Zach
walked me through the locker room when
that happened and you all had to turn to
Nick Foles in the huddle
yeah obviously we were playing the Rams
at the time and Carson never shows any
real emotion and for him to kind of sit
there on the field pointing at his knee
you kind of knew something was probably
pretty wrong and so they go over to the
sent they do the little me check and
he's just shaking his head as he was
walking out he walked into the locker
room but the team really didn't dwell on
the fact that he wasn't in there at that
point Carson was the MVP of the league
and no one kind of batted an eye
everyone was just kind of focusing on
their job I know foals and our senator
Jason Kent in a inter center Jason
Chelsea kind of got up right away and
they started taking snaps together I
mean that that moment for our team could
have gone one or two ways it was either
gonna be a rallying 2014 or we were
going to implode and the character of
the arc team kind of showed in that
moment obviously Carson was this use
part of our Super Bowl team we wouldn't
have been where we were without the
foundation that he lays the first 14
games of the season so obviously we
rallied around Nick but this team won't
have been where it will where we went
without Carson you know and in Zach Ertz
here in the Rich Eisen show you know I
know the dog masks and and how much fun
that is and that is a ton of fun where
you're you're sort of
recognizing the lack of confidence in
you outside of the locker room by
members of the media I'm raising my hand
I'm well I was one of them I'm not gonna
lie I understand that but for Nick Foles
to be asked after the game what the
message is he could have gone in that
direction right but instead he talked
about his own failures and how we as
people in this day and age that put on
Instagram and Twitter it's all about a
celebration of our successes greatness
and how failure is something that can be
used to make you better - who is this
guy
Zack to say something like that right
yeah that's kind of the Nick we all know
and love I think we live in a society
today with social media everything
that's kind of that instant that instant
like or that kind of favorite on Twitter
no one kind of wants to see you
struggling everyone kind of want that
instant gratification where that's not
real life everyone's going to go through
highs and lows especially in this
business of football it's never going to
be as good as you think it is or as bad
as you think it is and Nick is obviously
been through the wringer the past three
years you know he went to the RAM I
think in 2014 he got traded out there
and he was extremely positive excited
about that and it just didn't work out
as well as he anticipated and like you
said he was pretty much gonna walk away
from the game until Coast reads called
him kind of wanted him to come to the
back of 4 in the Kansas City and I've
spoken to him in the past about that
experience and that's when he kind of
said I started having fun playing
football again you know being in this
city in Philadelphia if you're losing at
times it's not the most fun because
these fans are so passionate they expect
us to win each and every week but this
this city right now is so much fun
playing for our team is probably the
closest team I've ever been a part of
and I thought Nick's message after the
game was brought on I don't think anyone
could have said it better than that yeah
and it's it really like I told Malcolm
earlier in the show it's made me a fan
as for life my wife - we've told our
children about that like we have nine we
have a nine six and four at home
you know we told them about that and I
do have to tell you cuz you know I know
you don't have kids yet with your wife
this day will come you know my
six-year-old looked at me took that in
and said to me because he's a patriot
fan dad that Zach Ertz touchdown
shouldn't have been a touchdown it's
what he said today we're trying you know
we're trying it's a couple that said was
there a moment when there was the review
of your touchdown where you thought for
a second maybe this was not a touchdown
Zach there was never a moment honestly I
promise you that I ever wavered and I
think that was a touchdown maybe I
thought they went over there just to
kind of look at it and makes her because
they have to review every touchdown in
the NFL but when they were over there
for like three minutes I'm looking at
Trenton who was just kneeling right
across to me and we're like there's no
way they could overturn this like
there's zero doubt in our mind they were
overturned that I don't know what would
happen to the city of Philadelphia they
would have been riots so I'm glad for
our city's sake that they didn't
overturn it and I don't think there was
any doubt I still don't understand what
took so long
well it's because the ball movement in
your hands as you left across the goal
line I thought this is a touchdown
because you took two steps at least
three steps before you were contacted
and then you'd of the ball in your hands
the way it turned James just like your
colleague from Pittsburgh it looked just
like that the way it turning your hands
and that's when I thought oh my gosh
maybe that is not a touchdown I
respectfully disagree a little bit okay
I think I caught the ball like the
five-yard line and ran in you did no you
did what I'm saying no exactly I'm with
you on that I agree and they named it
this was upheld properly I'm giving you
the impression of why people thought it
wasn't because we saw the ball turn in
Jesse James's hands in the same manner
diving across the goal line yeah like he
caught the ball and like as he was
falling he never like established
possession in the field of play he kind
of caught it and then reached over the
goal line it was like
in motion whereas mine I could have if I
did I pretty much caught the ball at the
50-yard line
and that's the same result because I
already had established myself in the
field of play I don't think it was it
was a right comparison between the two I
understand like when I cross the goal
line and who drove like a yard into the
end zone but then the ball kind of
popped out but it is what it is I'm just
glad they upheld it a couple more
minutes here with Zach Ertz Eagles tight
end
what conversation what's a conversation
like with a wife who has been there and
done that in her own right in the world
of soccer what what what are your
conversations like you've got a Lombardi
Trophy and your wife is one of the most
decorated on the planet in her
profession Zach yeah you know we're just
extremely proud and happy for one
another you know obviously is athletes
we have goals from the moment I started
playing football and she started playing
soccer she had a goal of winning a World
Cup and I had a goal of winning a Super
Bowl and so when we're watching the
other person do what they love and doing
it at a high level and enjoy that
success that's the more extremely happy
for them only because we know that
they're extremely happy in that moment
our relationship wasn't built on
athletic success we started dating in
college before I even knew she played
soccer or she knew that I played
football this season right now that
we're in with the sports is extremely
difficult at times but it's a ton of fun
too so we do a lot of long-distance at
times but at the end of the day like I
said family of short students never life
I'm extremely happy for all the success
you've had and she feels the same way
about me you have any advice marital
advice for Carson Wentz who just took
the plunge
oh his marriage is gonna be rock solid
he's a he went about it exactly how
you're supposed to do it he's a man of
of his faith and so is his wife and her
future wife I should say it's Beyonce
and they're amazing people and they're
gonna be a very great married couple
well Zach thanks for calling in
appreciate it have a blast at the parade
okay thank blessed don't be a black yeah
I'm looking forward to it I hope
everyone in Philly stays safe and enjoy
you got it and and when you're out here
in Los Angeles you know I'd love to have
you in show on on the show in person and
again I hope you can enjoy the parade
after the quarterback controversy we
just sparked between you and Trey Burke
it's up on twitter so hit that set oh
it's up on Twitter is it okay all right
Zach look out it's coming your way
thanks again you got that Zachary C
Earth's underscore 86 on Twitter the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience